[Musik]
hallo meine Lieben wir machen heute
honey glazed chicken es werden so
leckere Hähnchenteile und so richtig
schön herzhaft aber auch süß durch den
Honig eins meiner liebsten Rezepte und
es geht auch sehr sehr schnell ich fange
direkt an und schreib euch die ganz
genauen mengangaben hier unten in die
Infobox hier habe ich Hähnchenbrust
jetzt werde ich ja könnt ihr ganz
einfach selbst entscheiden jetzt werde
ich da so mundgerechte Stücke machen
oder ein bisschen größer als mundgerecht
also so dass sie nicht mit einem Haps
sondern mit zwei Haps im Mund sind und
dann mache ich auch schon die Marinade
die besteht bei mir aus Buttermilch und
bei mir war es heute so ich hatte gar
keine Buttermilch mehr da und da gibt's
einen ganz einfachen Trick ihr nehmt
euch Milch und Essig ich habe jetzt z.B
Apfelessig genommen oder alternativ geht
auch Zitrone schreibe ich euch auch ganz
genau in die Infobox wie viel Gramm ihr
da benötigt und dann einfach umrünen es
wird schon dicker bei mir ihr könntet
dann 15 Minuten warten dass es so ein
bisschen dicker wird müsst ihr aber gar
nicht weil das wird ja sowieso gleich in
der Marinade 30 bis 45 Minuten einfach
chillen und dann wird es automatisch
[Musik]
dick
zur Buttermilch gebe ich jetzt noch
Knoblauch da dürft ihr bei diesem Rezept
nicht sparen also ich mache da wirklich
Knoblauch jetzt erstmal hier in die
Marinade dann mache ich noch Knoblauch
in die Panade das macht schon wirklich
was mit dem Geschmack das gebe ich hier
direkt zur Buttermilch und dann
eigentlich nur noch drei simple Zutaten
Salz Pfeffer am besten frisch gemahlen
so schmeckt der am besten und
Paprikapulver edelsüß Schärfe kommt
gleich auch noch mit dazu aber nicht
hier sondern gleich in der Panade und
dann einmal das Hähnchen da reingeben
alles gut verrühren und zugedeckt wie
gesagt 30 bis 60 Minuten einfach ruhen
lassen und einziehen lassen wenn ihr
Zeit habt könnt ihr das sogar am
Vorabend schon machen ihr könnt es auch
stundenlang marinieren lassen das ist
vollkommen euch überlassen aber wenn ihr
eben keine Zeit habt oder Hunger habt
dann sind 30 Minuten auch
[Musik]
okay
für die Panade brauchen wir auch nur
ganz wenige Zutaten super unkompliziert
jetzt erstmal das Mehl hier ich gebe
jetzt einfach schon mal alles in die
auflauffor dann nehme ich mir Paprika
edelsüß jetzt wie angekündigt ein
bisschen Chili ich mag es ja nicht so
scharf wenn ihr es scharf mit gibt gerne
mehr dazu Salz und Pfeffer natürlich und
Achtung geheimte Backpulver mit dazu es
gibt noch mal so eine richtig schöne
krosste knusprige Panade das könnt ihr
jetzt erstmal vor ab miteinander
verrühren und jetzt nach und nach die
Milch dazu geben und alles schön glatt
rühren und ganz zum Schluss kommt noch
das Ei mit dazu so fast hätte ich es
vergessen natürlich noch schön die
Knoblauchzehe hier reingeben und dann
habt ihr so eine Panade die ist nicht
fest aber auch nicht flüssig zeig euch
mal die Konsistenz genao muss es sein
damit das auch schön am Hähnchen haften
bleibt und dann nehmen wir uns jetzt die
Hähnchenstücke und wälzen die in der
Panade aber ihr könnt auch parallel
schon mal euer Fett vorbereiten und D
zeige ich euch gleich auch einen richtig
genialen Trick wie ihr ohne Friteuse
ganz genau wissen könnt wann euer
Fritierfett soweit
[Musik]
ist
ich habe jetzt hier meine Pfanne mit
Frittierfett und ihr nehmt euch jetzt am
besten ein Holzstiel oder einen
schaschlgspieß und geht da einmal ins
Fett rein wenn die Bläschen jetzt in
schneller Geschwindigkeit aufsteigen
dann ist das Fett soweit wenn sie
langsam aufsteigen ist das Fett noch zu
kalt und wenn sie zu schnell aufsteigen
und alles blubbert dann ist es zu heiß
ich hatte jetzt mein Herd auf Stufe 8
von ne bin aber jetzt wieder R unter auf
Stufe 3 von neun ihr könnt halt nicht
immer auf der gleichen Stufe bleiben
wenn ihr lange frittiert weil ihr müsst
euch vorstellen dass die Wärme ja da
auch gespeichert wird und das dann
einfach auch irgendwann zu heiß wird man
muss es immer so ein bisschen
kalibrieren daher immer schönen
Holzstiel dabei haben und kleiner Tipp
von mir wenn ihr den Holzstiel immer
wieder rein steckt ins Fett irgendwann
gibt er keine Signale mehr dann braucht
ihr auch einen neuen Holzstil und jetzt
gebe ich hier mein Hähnchen schön ins
Fett aber lass das noch einmal so ein
bisschen runtertropfen und dann wird das
einfach mal schön frittiert und nebenbei
machen wir noch schön die honeylaze
fertig die besteht nämlich aus nur drei
Zutaten ich habe hier Honig Ketchup und
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Sojasoße
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sieht das nicht gut aus Leute und ich
muss sagen es war überhaupt nicht Zeit
auf W nicht also außer jetzt natürlich
dass es einziehen muss ne das muss man
sich so ein bisschen einplanen aber
ansonsten habe ich das in einer Ladung
frittiert und die Menge die reicht jetzt
so für drei Personen als Beilage ich
würde jetzt noch Reis dazu kochen und
Salat ganz e man kann sich auch einfach
so gönnen ich probiere jetzt mal für
euch boah oh mein
Gott Leute ihr beiden hinter der
Kamera ich werde gerade ganz neidisch
angeguckt aber wir probieren nlichich
alle zusammen das schmeckt so gut es ist
so krass durch Backpulver ist es so ein
richtig luftiger Crunch wenn man
reinbeißt dann die süße Knoblauch dazu
Bo das schmeckt richtig lecker lass uns
das Video beenden und lass un das
einfach zusammen gönnen also ich wünsche
euch jetzt ganz viel Spaß beim
Nachmachen und sage bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss das so lecker ze von ze die Süße
ist genau perfekt ich habe erst Angst
gehab wegen dem Honig das wird viel zu
süß aber das passt perfekt zusammen und
das Hähnchen ist auch voll zart trotz
ver stimmt weil meistens so D nicht
durch ist oder dass es zu durch ist
volun Leute
aber
wir schnell nicht würde das
in nur panieren aber gut in der
Zwischenzeit räumst du auch oder mach
sonst
was
[Musik]